(whooshing)
- Good morning, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe,
and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all the
world's major problems.
I started the Believe Life series
to try to expand beyond just
the world of entrepreneurship
and try to learn some other
skills, resources, ideas,
to help us become a more
complete human being.
Today we're going to learn
some hiking tips for beginners.
And as always guys,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it down
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(bouncy uplifting music)
(light uplifting music)
- Do you ever wonder what separates
those living an elite life
from those who live a mediocre one?
Do you think it's their bank account?
Guess again.
They make time for adventure.
Make.
Time.
For adventure.
Don't get me wrong, there's many things
that separate an elite
life from a mediocre one,
but today I want to talk about
memories and experiences.
These are things that we all have, right?
But at what level and what frequency?
Ultimately guys, life, in my opinion
is and should be an adventure.
Over the past year and a half
I've studied countless
world-class leaders,
and something that I've noticed
they all have in common,
that they constantly create
memorable experiences.
In 2015, I made it a point
to make time for adventure.
And during the summer of 2015,
I probably fit in more adventures
than I've probably put in
in my entire life.
And it was life-changing.
Don't get me wrong, I've
always loved hiking,
but I never found the time to do it
until I changed my mindset.
I ultimately decided to make time,
and I planned a new place
to explore every week.
And I planned my life and work around it.
Some trips were day hikes,
some were half-days.
Some were weekends.
Some were four days.
The point being, no matter
what my schedule was,
I always found time,
whether it be a long or short adventure,
and I've honestly never
been more fulfilled
or happier in my life.
I mean really, what's the
point of doing anything
if you're not having fun
and it doesn't elevate you emotionally?
Now, I know we all have things
that we must do, day to day,
that may not be fun, can get a bit bland,
so why not make time to
take a mini adventure,
a half day or a weekend,
every week, every month.
This will snap you out of any complacency
you may be feeling.
Don't let yourself be complacent.
Complacency, it's the killer
of dreams and ambition.
You can start right now
by making a list of adventures
that you want to take
throughout the rest of the year.
(light uplifting music)
- Hi, my name's John
and today we're going to do
a little beginner's intro
to hiking.
And one of the things
that I love about hiking
is that it truly is very, very simple.
You put one foot in front of the other,
you get out into a beautiful
natural area like this,
and that is the essence of hiking.
Of course, there are a
few tips and suggestions
that will make the beginner's experience
a little bit easier,
and will avoid some of the common pitfalls
that people without experience come across
when they go outside.
First things first, I always
like to talk about the feet.
Make sure that you have
appropriate footwear on.
These boots that I'm wearing today
are more of my heavier-duty hiking boots.
It is also appropriate if
you're going on easier terrain
to use running shoes or
lightweight hiking shoes,
even Tevas or other hiking-style
sandals can be adequate
if you know what you're doing
and the terrain is more forgiving.
For dress, I always like to
dress particularly lightly.
Shorts, lightweight long pants, a t-shirt,
and maybe a jacket if it's a cooler day
that you might store in your pack
if you start out and it's warmer
but it might be raining later on.
As far as carrying some things with you,
some very essential or basic things.
A day pack is really good for
your shorter hiking trips,
and in that day pack, or
carrying with you, have water.
Please bring plenty of water.
If you're going to go for an hour or two,
one water bottle's sufficient.
Multiple hour hikes will
take multiple water bottles.
A little bit of food, some snacks.
Good old raisins and peanuts, aka gorp,
and then just an extra jacket.
Always be prepared
even if there's no rain in the forecast
it might rain on you,
I always bring an extra jacket like that.
First aid kit, sunblock,
those are pretty much the essentials.
As far as planning a place to go hiking,
almost anybody in this country
lives near a beautiful park
or a wild natural area.
Today we're in Montana de Oro
State Park here in California.
As you can see, thousands of acres,
wonderful hiking trails here.
If you're beginning, I
would pick out a trail
that might be two or
three miles in length,
maybe a little bit shorter,
pretty moderate terrain.
As you get used to it, you can work up
and do heavier-duty trails
with more up-and-down terrain.
Eight or 10 miles with
a lot of up-and-down
would be a really full
hiking day for folks.
That's hiking in a nutshell,
and I hope that that helps
beginners get a feel for it
and avoid some of the common problems
that happen to folks
who don't really know what they're doing
out there while they're hiking.
- Have a plan.
99% of the time that I
travel in the backcountry,
I do so alone.
Somethin' I just really enjoy.
So it's really important,
on the front end of my trips
that I have a plan.
And so what I do is I
do some research online,
look at websites at the
area I'm going to be in,
I look at a map to see where
I'm going to park my truck.
I look at the various
destinations I want to get to,
how long, how many
miles it's going to take
for me to get there,
how long it's going to
take to hike those miles.
And the other thing I look at is weather
so that I can anticipate
if there's going to be any
precipitation, rain, or snow,
and I know the predicted high temperatures
and the low temperatures
so I can pack accordingly.
I always carry a compass and a map
when I'm traveling in the backcountry.
What I do is I take
the National Geographic
Trails Illustrated map,
it's a big color map,
and I'll take photocopies of the sections
or the areas I'm going to be hiking in,
and I put those in a gallon Ziploc bag.
It allows me to travel lighter,
it protects those documents,
I can write on the maps
and not damage the original map,
and it's very lightweight
for me to travel in the
backcountry that way.
And also I carry my iPhone
which has a GPS built
into it, with a Topo app.
And I just run the phone in airplane mode
and so it conserves battery power
and I pull that out every once in a while
if I want to double check where I am at.
But primarily, I use my map and compass.
I leave a detailed itinerary
with at least two people.
One is always my wife,
I tell here exactly where
I'm going to park my pickup
and what my plan is for
while I'm in the backcountry,
where I'm going to be and so on,
and the other person I
leave this information with
is a good friend of mine
who knows the area and has
the ability to come and get me
if I run into trouble.
Most of the time when
you read about someone
who's experienced a
tragedy in the backcountry
while traveling solo,
it's because they didn't
tell anybody where they went.
- Day hikes.
This portion of the video is
going to be for day hikes that are
one, two, three miles.
If I'm goin' on a day hike
that's one, two, or three miles
these are the items
that I'm going to bring.
First thing I focus on, food and water.
What I have here today,
it's perfect for one, two, three miles,
sometimes I'll bring a little more.
I just have some granola and some peanuts,
simple snack to snack on.
Sometimes I'll bring extra granola bars,
sometimes even a can of soup,
depending on the area that I'm going.
So that's food.
Water, usually I'll
just bring one canteen,
and if I'm going for longer distances,
usually I'll bring a bladder pack
or if I know the area that I'm goin' in,
I'll bring a water filter.
This way I can fill up my canteen
when I stop near a stream
or somethin' like that.
So that's food and water covered
for a one to three mile hike.
Protection from the elements,
usually I'll just bring a poncho,
and this will basically keep me dry
and all my gear that I have dry.
A cheap alternative
would be a big trash bag.
You can get them fairly cheap,
just cut a hole in the
top and put your arms in
and there you go, you got your own poncho,
very lightweight and cheap.
I would recommend not
buying dollar store ponchos
'cause they tear very easily.
If you're goin' in an area
where there's a small footpath
and you scrape up against a branch,
chances are the poncho's going to tear
if you buy the cheap-quality ones.
So I'd recommend maybe gettin' one
that's a little more high-quality
than the dollar store brand.
so that's protection from the elements
for a one to three mile hike.
What I like to call just-in-case items.
Again, fire starting,
if for some reason you do get lost.
Very simple, bring a
lighter, bring two lighters,
bring three lighters,
keep 'em in different locations,
because if for some reason
you lose your backpack
and all your fire stuff
is in the backpack,
what are you going to do?
So keep a lighter in your pocket,
maybe keep a lighter in your jacket,
I have another one in
my inside pocket here,
and keep a couple in your backpack.
Practice usin' a ferro rod of course.
But that's the basics of fire,
keep somethin' to light a fire on you,
and a lighter in my
opinion is the best way.
Another thing, just-in-case item,
bring some flashlights.
I have this cheap headlamp here.
This actually cost $10.
It's rechargeable, I did a test,
the battery, I kept it
on the highest setting,
it lasts for about 11 hours
and it still didn't die
so I just shut it off at that point,
I determined it was very useful.
$10 on Amazon,
if I can remember where
I got it from or the name
I'll put it in the
description for you guys.
So bring some type of light.
I have another light on my keychain here.
It's a very small light
but it's very effective,
it's a high-powered LED light.
I'd recommend bringin'
multiple lights if you can,
small flashlights work fine,
you don't need anything
hi-tech or expensive.
And I actually keep another headlamp
in my pocket here just in case,
it stays with me at all times
in my jacket just in case.
This is my better
headlamp that I purchased.
Just in case you do get lost
and you're out longer than expected
and it does become night
you want to have light
to be able to navigate.
And that's basically it for day hikes.
Something I usually bring too,
just this little foam
pad, just for comfort.
If I stop to sit down for a second,
put it on my bum, sit
down, it's nice and cozy
so my butt doesn't go numb.
So that's somethin' simple there,
and I also use this to
fan the fire sometimes.
So just some comfortable
items that I bring.
And that's the basics for
a one to three mile hike.
It's not too extensive,
you don't need a lot
when you're goin' out hiking.
Just focus on the area that you're in,
know the area that you're in,
and know how to get out, just in case.
For longer hikes I would
bring all this stuff
that I just explained.
I would also bring a water
filter, very important,
and I would also bring this Mylar top.
It's great for protection
from the elements,
if I had to make an emergency shelter
I could put this up in a lean-to fashion,
have a fire in front of me,
and it should keep me
warm the entire night.
I've actually done it before.
I highly recommend these Mylar tops.
I believe it was like $15 on Amazon.
Lightweight, very very versatile item.
And they come in a couple
of different colors,
but this is my favorite
piece of kit that I have
and I highly recommend it.
I bought one, I liked it
so much I bought two more.
So that says a lot.
If you're just getting into hiking
I recommend bring more than you need.
If you can bear the weight on your back,
bring more than you need
and then over time
you'll get used to the
gear that you don't need,
and little by little you'll
have less and less and less.
That's basically how I
decided on what gear I should bring.
I went and my pack was a
little heavy in the beginning,
but over time I was like,
"I've never even used this
on the last three hikes
"so I'm going to take it out of my bag."
And then you just go on from there.
So that's it.
Get a nice comfortable backpack.
Over time obviously
you don't want to spend
$100 on a backpack.
If you're goin' out
hikin' for the first time,
get somethin' cheap and just learn
and grow and get out there
and experience the woods.
And tell me about your adventure.
- Respect the backcountry.
What I mean by this
is that when I am in the
backcountry traveling alone
whether I'm scaling a steep
slope to get up a peak
or I'm crossing a stream,
I keep a slogan in the back
of my mind, and that is:
Remember where you are.
And what that reminds me
is that if I were to get
hurt right at that moment,
I am days away, potentially,
from anyone coming to help me.
So it helps me to be vigilant
when I'm hiking down the trail
or stepping from boulder to boulder.
Most times when people have
accidents in the backcountry
is due to laziness.
They're just not paying attention.
I mean, I get it.
You get fatigued, it's late in the day,
and you're just not paying attention
when you're puttin' your
full weight down on a rock,
you just assume that rock is stable,
and you can't, when
you're traveling alone.
You get an injury by yourself
and there's nobody there to help you.
So remembering where you are
just helps you to be vigilant at all times
so that you minimize your risks.
- And then last on the
list is emergency shelter.
We call 'em a bivy.
And here's a two-person
bivy in a small container,
and here's a one-person bivy.
You can see how small these are,
you just throw it in your pack,
and if you never need it
you never know it's there.
But when you do need it,
it'll save your life.
So definitely recommend that.
One of the things I like to carry
on some big trips in the north Cascades
is my SPOT 2 messenger.
I can check in with my wife and kids,
let 'em know that I'm okay,
and if I do need help
I can hit the button.
It works with satellites,
and it works very well.
It's been out for a long time.
I also recommend that you
maybe bring a plastic bag.
This is great for shelter as
well as keepin' everything dry
if you're in a torrential downpour.
You get wet, you get
cold, you're in trouble.
Things to think about is weight.
If you go on a trip,
you obviously got to keep your weight
in proportion to what you can carry.
So scale down or scale up things
depending on where you're going.
Use common sense.
Are you takin' a long
trip, are there hazards,
is there going to be weather problems?
Be able to deal with everything.
Nobody wants to call search and rescue
and nobody wants to find themselves
spending an unwanted
night in the wilderness.
(light upbeat music)
- What are the main categories
or classes of hiking boots?
- There's four main styles and
categories of hiking boots.
The first would be the low-cut,
ultra-light hiking boots,
and then it would be just a
general, all-purpose hiker.
And then you're going to go
with a little bit heavier
in a backpacking hiking boot,
and then the heaviest and most durable
would be the mountaineering
and winter hiking boots.
The ultra-light hiking
boots are designed for
the backpacker who wants to cut down
on their weight on their trips.
Most of them are not waterproof,
they're mostly lightweight, breathable,
but they provide for easier
comfort through the day,
they're going to keep your feet dry,
even if you go through water
they're going to breathe a lot faster
so you are going to dry out quicker.
Most of 'em do have a
pretty aggressive tread
to kind of keep going through
most of the rugged terrain in Idaho.
A lot of customers
or a lot of people who
are going out hiking
prefer to not have ankle support.
A lot of people do.
People with ankle injuries especially
don't like to have the hightop boots
because it rubs on scars or scar tissue.
And so we get a lot of people
asking for a lower cut,
still aggressive and still rugged shoe.
- Now, I've heard that
one pound on your feet
actually equals five pounds on your back.
Is that true?
- Yeah, absolutely.
The feet are moving all day,
and if you think about
lugging one of these around
as opposed to one of
these, it's way different.
This is three pounds a foot,
this is not even 16 ounces,
it'd be like 12 ounces a foot.
So you're cutting a lot of weight,
and they're moving all day.
And so at the end of the day
you're going to have a lot
more energy wearing these out
than you are when you
wear these heavier-duty
mountaineering boots.
- Seeing I'm more of a
heavy-weight backpacker
I go on a lot rougher terrain,
I'm carrying weights of 30, 40,
maybe even 50 pounds or more,
what type of boot am I going to
step up to in that situation?
- When you're in that situation
you're going to step up to an
all-around backpacking boot.
Most of them are an all-leather
so you're going to get
a lot of waterproofing,
you can use a Nikwax
or something like that
to also waterproof them as well.
And most of them have Vibram soles,
and so they're going to provide
a little bit more traction,
and a little more stability.
And it's a lot wider of a base
than a traditional hiking shoe,
and so it's going to provide
that stability left and right.
One of the main things to keep in mind
which a lot of people don't know
is trying on boots
later on during the day.
Your feet tend to swell
as you're standing around
and walking around,
so knowing that your feet
are going to be a little bit different,
even a half size different
later in the day,
is going to help when you are
tired at the end of a hike.
So trying on shoes later in the day
definitely helps cuz
it's more of a true fit.
- Is there anything else I can do in-store
to make sure that the
boot is going to work?
I know some stores offer
incline ramps or other devices.
Can you maybe speak to that just quickly?
- Absolutely.
An incline ramp is crucial
when trying out a boot.
You definitely want to lace your boot up
like you're going to wear it,
and then start at the top and
stutter step your way down
and make sure that your toes
aren't hitting the front.
Cuz if they're hitting the front
four or five steps down an incline ramp,
they're going to hit on the
way down from a mountain.
And then you turn around and walk back up
and make sure that your heel
isn't slipping in the back,
cuz that would cause a
blister pretty quickly.
- So once I've actually tested the shoes,
picked 'em out, purchased them,
what do I need to do prior to
hitting the trail with them?
Do I just break 'em out of
the box and go for a hike?
What do I do?
- Prior to taking them
out on your first trip
or your first adventure
would be just wearing
them around the house
for a short amount of time.
A lot of these, the stiffer ones,
are going to take a long time to break in.
Some people have had 'em
on for two, three years
and still haven't broken 'em in.
So definitely taking them on
short walks around the block.
If you've got a dog and
you're walking a dog,
or even taking them on little mini hikes,
that way you're breaking them in
but you're still not committed to them
when you're out there and
you don't have anything else
to change into.
- You only need a handful of garments
to stay warm, dry, and comfortable
in rain, wind, or snow
so that you can enjoy views like this.
Hi, I'm Jonathon Simons
and I'm a wildlife tracker
and bushcraft instructor.
And in my spare time, a keen
birdwathcher and hill walker.
So I spend a lot of my time outdoors.
Every time I do go out,
I use the same versatile clothing system
known as the layering system
to keep me warm, dry, and comfortable.
And today, I'm going to
show you how it works.
I'm working with my friends at Go Outdoors
who have all the know-how on outdoor kit
at their fingertips.
The light and packable clothing
that forms the layering system
is designed to be kept in your rucksack
so that it can be pulled
out at a moment's notice.
To see how it works,
we need to rewind to the start of the day.
(tape rewinding)
The first part of the layering
system is the base layer.
It's designed to trap a
thin layer of warm air
against my body
and pools, or wicks, sweat
vapor away from the skin.
It also keeps me very warm and dry.
I'm wearing a base layer
made of merino wool.
Its fibers are so fine it
doesn't itch or scratch.
Merino also helps neutralize body odor.
And it's an environmentally-friendly,
renewable fabric.
There's one base layer fabric
that you need to avoid,
and that's cotton.
Cotton soaks up sweat like a sponge,
and this is bad news
because when cotton gets wet,
it draws heat away from your body.
And this can lead to hypothermia.
Hypothermia is a potentially
lethal condition,
and can be contracted in
surprisingly mild weather.
So unless you're in a hot climate,
avoid wearing cotton clothing.
And of course, avoid wearing
cotton underwear and socks too.
Well, it's getting cooler
so it's time to throw on the
next part of my layering system
which is the mid layer.
Now, the mid layer is
designed to trap body heat
and to allow sweat vapor
to carry on moving through
the layering system.
The most popular mid
layer fabric is fleece,
as it's affordable,
durable, and quick-drying.
The thicker the fleece,
the more heat it traps.
So you want a mid-weight
fleece for colder weather,
and a thin, or micro-fleece like this one
for milder conditions.
As you gain altitude
the temperature drops,
so remember, on the summit
it could be quite cold,
even though it was really
warm down in the car park.
But ambient temperature's
only part of the story.
Wind and rain can have a big impact
on just how cold and
uncomfortable it can feel.
Which is where the next part
of the layering system comes in.
This outer layer, known as the shell,
blocks wind and rain.
It also allows my sweat vapor
to leave the layering system.
I'm wearing a waterproof Paramo shell,
and I'm feeling very comfortable indeed.
Lovely.
- There are three types of shell:
Paramo, membrane, and coated nylon.
They all do a great job in
keeping out the elements,
but they vary in how quickly
they allow sweat vapor
to move from the inside to
the outside of the garment.
Paramo's Nikwax Analogy fabric,
which is what John is wearing,
and membranes,
are the two types of waterproof
and breathable material
that are best suited for active use.
Paramo is very breathable,
and great at keeping you comfortable
in many weather conditions.
But the material is heavier
than some membranes and coated nylon.
Membranes such as Gore-Tex,
eVent, and Dew Point
are lighter and more packable than Paramo,
but they don't breathe
quite as effectively.
The third type of outer
layer is a coated nylon.
These shells are designed
for passive activity
such as walking the dog,
short rambles with a day sack,
or hiking to the pub.
Coated nylons are less
expensive and less breathable
than Paramo or membranes,
and will feel sweaty
during arduous activities.
- You can use the layering
system on your legs too.
You can layer a pair of
merino or synthetic leggings
underneath your wind-resistant
summer trekking trousers,
and you can pull on a pair
of breathable and waterproof overtrousers
should the weather come in.
An alternative to the
legwear layering system
is a pair of soft-shell
trousers like these.
Soft-shell is a popular legwear material,
as it's time-consuming
to adjust multiple layers on the move.
- Hi there guys, I'm out
here enjoying nature again,
just next to a nice little
village on the Alps.
And because I'm always out and about
doing all sorts of adventures,
a few people are asking me about hiking.
Like "What sort of gear do
you take when you go hiking,
"overnight camping, and so on?
"What do you need, what do you
actually take when you go?"
So here I've selected 15 items
that I consider as the basic kit,
things that you should be taking
if you go on that sort of activity.
So let's get started with
number one, is your tent.
This might be for one
to three or more people,
maybe three seasons, four season,
it all depends on what sort of conditions
you're going to be facing.
Number two is some sort of isolating mat.
The main function of this
is not only to give you some
comfort against the hard ground
underneath your sleeping bag,
but also to protect you
from cold and humidity
coming from the ground.
Talking about cold, number
three is your sleeping bag.
Make sure that the temperature
rating of your sleeping bag
is adequate to the temperatures
that you're going to be facing.
Consider that at night time
the temperature can drop quite a lot.
Number four is your kitchen.
It's a kitchen kit, really.
So here's your stove.
Several models out there:
Gas, alcohol, multi-fuel, and so on.
Your pots and eating utensils.
Number five is one of my favorites
is your food package,
breakfast, lunch, dinner,
trail snacks, and so on.
I'm going to be talking about
all this gear on another video,
giving more details and being
more specific, but yeah.
So that was number five.
Number six is water bottles.
Not only to keep you
hydrated during the walk
and during the camping,
but also to measure water for cooking,
and a lot of them can be used
with water purification systems.
Which is our next item, number seven.
This could be a filter,
you can use water purification tablets,
maybe even boil water,
but it's quite important to treat water.
You don't want to get contaminated,
especially when you're
camping on remote areas.
Number eight is a torch.
I personally like headlamps.
Hands-free, walking at night,
cooking after dark, and so on.
Very handy, make sure
you take spare batteries.
Number nine is a first aid kit
with a multi-tool or a knife.
I make sure that this is
always in a waterproof bag,
I do the same with the rest of my gear,
but particularly with this one here.
Number 10 is your personal hygiene kit.
This is where your
toothpaste, toothbrush is.
You might want to take a
small microfiber towel,
and your toilet paper also
kept in a small dry bag.
Number 11 is your clothing.
Just a package of fresh, dry, warm layers
so if the temperature drops
you want to make sure
you're warm and protected,
and that's it.
So talking about protection,
we got to number 12,
which is a rain jacket and rain pants.
When we're outdoors, we're always exposed.
Rain, wind, snow and so on.
You want to make sure you're dry and warm.
They also give you a lot of
protection against the wind.
The next item is a map covering
the entire area and compass,
and ideally some basic
orienteering skills as well.
Alright, number 14 is a small pouch
with your wallet, phone,
and keys, and so on.
Here you can also keep
copies of reservations
like an entry for a national park
or some sort of ticket for
transportation and so on.
And lastly, our last item,
number 15, a backpack.
Obviously something
appropriate for hiking.
It must be comfortable and
with capacity big enough
for all your gear, and
maybe a little bit more
so that you don't have to pack
everything extremely precise,
you've got a little bit of
margin to play around with.
Right, so these are pretty
much the 15 basic items
that I consider as the
basic kit for hiking,
staying overnight.
- Thank you guys so much for
watching, I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video,
what was the message that you took home
that you're going to immediately
apply somehow in your life
or maybe in your business.
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give real
quick credit to Edward.
Edward, thank you so much
for picking a copy of
my book Your One Word.
I hope you're enjoying the read, man,
and I'm so appreciative for your support.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, have an amazing day,
and I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)